hey guys quick note my brand new book
the authoritarian moment is out
this week go pick up a copy today i
think it's really important
it's about how all of the major
institutions of american society have
now been
taken over and weaponized by the left
against dissent
it's not just about how they did it it's
about how we take those institutions
back
check out the link in the description
below and get a copy of the
authoritarian moment
you're talking about masking up hundreds
of millions of people at this point
based on circumstances that have been
defined by the cdc director
as somewhat rare the only data that have
been presented are a breakout case in
provincetown
and an indian study that has not been
verified yet
but even if you accept all that the
incentive structures still make no sense
so joe biden was asked to explain why he
changed his standards on
post-vaccination and masking and here he
is not being able to explain himself of
course
in may you made it sound like a vaccine
with a ticket to losing the mass
that getting vaccinated made a gigantic
difference
and what happened was the new variant
came along
they didn't get vaccinated it was spread
more rapidly
and people more people were getting sick
that's the difference
okay well that's not actually the
difference the unvaccinated are in just
as much danger as they ever were
the vaccinated are in just as little
danger as they ever were so actually the
calculus did not change
the only thing that changed here is that
everybody panic
that's what changed here by the way
biden did say that right he said if
you're a vaccinated unmask
this was joe biden just a couple of
months ago it's vaxxed
or masked that by the way is
is a lot more coherent than what he's
saying now
you'll call it last year by the way joe
biden it's now been a year since this
joe biden
said last year quote i'm not going to
shut down the country
i'm not going to shut down the economy
i'm going to shut down
the virus oh really then why won't your
white house rule out further lockdowns
yesterday one of the white house press
secretaries came out and explained that
the white house would not be ruling out
for their lockdowns
if scientists come to you at some point
down the line and say
it is our opinion that there should be
shutdowns and there should be school
closures
you would do that well we listened to
like i said we listened to the cdc and
the the expert and the
and their guidance um are you know are
the cdc is a is a body that is very well
respected
and uh we file again we follow their
guidance the cdc is not a body that is
well respected
is not well respected by me it is not
well respected by people who watch the
cdc
i do not respect the cdc they've changed
their guidance 1 000 times not based on
good data but based on this
sort of panicked squirrel-like
insistence that every new outlier case
is a rationale for public lockdowns and
masked mandates without any sort of
actual understanding
of how the human mind works or how
people act
this is madness it's absolutely crazy by
the way even the the mandates that are
now being announced by biden
even though those don't make any sort of
internal logical sense so joe biden
yesterday announced that federal
employees
are going to have to get vaccinated or
they're going to have to test
like every week so here's what job i
need to say
every federal government employee will
be asked to attest
to their vaccination status anyone who
does not attest
or is not vaccinated will be required to
mask no matter where they work test
one or two times a week to see if
they've they've acquired
covet socially distance
and generally will not be allowed to
travel for work
okay so um let's just note something
they said that they're gonna be tested
like once a week
that's completely ineffective you test
people for covered once a week
what happens in the intervening week
what if they test
negative on monday and then they have
covet on tuesday wednesday thursday
friday saturday or sunday
so no this this doesn't make any sense
at all like at all
but it's not meant to make sense it's
not meant to be related to reality
it's meant to create a forever reliance
on government with no actual
endpoint i've been saying this for weeks
at this point there is
no end goal there's no end goal if your
end goal is zero coveted it's because
you're a fool
no one seriously believes that zero
covet is a serious goal it's not
to pretend that zero covid is is
reachable or attainable
is contra all available science at this
point and yet that seems to be what
they're going for
because obviously we're not worried
about overwhelming hospitals nobody's
even mentioned that
we're not even worried about getting
people availability of the vaccine
all we're worried about right now is
this idea that we have to have zero
coverage zero covet is not a real goal
but it's the only goal that would make
any sense of what they're trying to do
right now
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did go ahead and
hit that subscribe button so you stay up
to date with all our future content